В прошлом уроке мы разобрали архитектуру. Что бывает внутри модели. Это первая ось — корневой теории. Сейчас вторая ось — какие подходы к генерации существуют, то есть способы вообще взаимодействия с моделью. Сразу скажу, то, что мы сейчас разберём, может показаться знакомым или простым. Это нормально. Задача урока — зафиксировать систему. Логика этих подходов работает в любом инструменте и плюс-минус везде выглядит на самом деле одинаково.
Нам нужны предсказуемые механизмы, которые мы переиспользуем дальше, когда пойдём по конкретным инструментам.
Почему важно это отметить и запомнить? Очень важно здесь сохранить формулировку. У разных инструментов разный уровень контроля и разный интерфейс.
Где-то ты буквально видишь, с чем работаешь: слайдер, кнопка, поле, возможно, визуализация того, что ты делаешь, а где-то конкретный механизм спрятан, и единственный способ его найти — это знать, как он называется.
Эти названия — ключ к любому новому инструменту. Поэтому то, что мы рассматриваем, именно в формулировке, нужно запомнить.
Логика всего процесса достаточно простая. Когда у вас задача — сначала выбираете подход, потом под подход выбираете модель, а не наоборот.
Нужна серия с одним персонажем — подход Reference Based, и под него выбираете модель, которая его хорошо поддерживает.
Нужно поменять одну деталь на изображении — подход In Painting — под него соответствующая модель.
В конце я покажу вам карту подходов, которая будет работать на любых моделях.
Когда выйдет новая банана или новая версия Mid Journey, в них будут те же самые базовые режимы, и карта останется актуальной.
Разберем мы четыре базовых подхода, которые покрывают почти всю работу дизайнера, именно в плане работы с визуалом.
Text to Image, Image to Image, Reference Based, In Painting, South Painting.
Итак, первый, самый базовый подход — Text to Image. Вы пишете prompt, модель рисует изображение с нуля.
Никакого входного визуала, никаких референсов, только описание словами.
Это режим по умолчанию, во всех инструментах вы наверняка уже им пользовались.
Открываете Mid Journey, пишете prompt — это Text to Image.
Crius Flux — то же самое, Nano Banana, ChatGPT — все одно и то же.
Везде этот подход основной.
Когда мы его применяем?
Первый проход по задаче, когда нужно прикинуть, как вообще может выглядеть результат.
Когда нет исходника и нужно начинать с нуля.
Когда у нас иллюстрации и арт-визуал, где нет необходимости опираться на конкретный референс.
И эксперименты со стилем, когда хочется быстро увидеть, что выдает модель.
Когда мы не берем этот подход, когда у нас уже есть визуал и нужно его доработать — это другой подход.
Когда нужна точная серия в одном стиле, Text to Image ее не удержит.
Когда нужно поменять одну деталь, переписывать prompt и генерировать заново — это лотерея.
Тут, я думаю, так понятно, что контроль здесь самый низкий из всех подходов.
Модель сама решает, какая будет композиция, ракурс, освещение.
Можно влиять promptом, конечно, но не управлять полностью.
Главное ограничение здесь — непредсказуемость.
И непредсказуемость нам нужна там, где мы используем креативные модели для генерации.
Мы еще чуть позже в pipeline этот подход уложим.
Следующий подход называется Image to Image.
Вы даете модели исходное изображение и какой-то prompt.
Модель переделывает изображение под prompt.
Главный параметр, который здесь определяет все — это denoising strength.
Иногда его называют просто strength, иногда image weight, иногда control weight и так далее.
Но это всегда про одно и то же — насколько сильно модель отходит от исходника.
Как правило, значение этого параметра варьируется от 0 до 1 или от 0% до 100%.
И давай разберем по спектру, когда и что нам выбирать.
Низкий denoising от 0% до 40% — это модель помощника.
Она почти не меняет исходник, что-то подкрашивает, чуть-чуть добавляет деталей, используется для легкой полировки.
Например, есть готовое изображение, нужно слегка усилить настроение или добавить акценты освещения — ставим до 40%.
Средний denoising от 0,5 до 0,7 — это самый рабочий диапазон.
Модель сохраняет общую композицию и крупные формы, но перерисовывает поверх новой стилистики.
Сюда попадает большая часть практики — стилизация фотографий под иллюстрацию, перенос стиля, обновление визуала и так далее.
И высокий denoising от 0,8 до 1, до 100%.
Модель использует исходник только как структурную подсказку и рисует почти заново.
Композиция может уехать, цвета меняются, детали другие — используйте, когда исходник — это грубый коллаж или скетч, который нужно превратить в финальный визуал.
Запоминаем простой принцип.
Низкий denoising — модель помощник, средний — модель напарник, высокий — модель уже художник по мотивам вашего исходника.
Все главные модели поддерживают image to image, но не во всех моделях есть возможность этот параметр менять.
Например, Flux 2 в Cree дает отличный контроль.
В Mid Journey это работает по фиксированным значениям.
Либо почти то же самое, либо сильные изменения.
Варьировать этот параметр там нельзя.
Ну и в каких-нибудь моделях проприетарных, если, например, в Gemini при работе с нано-бананом ты закидываешь изображение, то там ты в целом не можешь этот параметр менять.
Все зависит только от твоего описания.
Поэтому в зависимости от того, как ты хочешь преобразовать изображение, мы используем разные модели.
Если ты хочешь сильно его изменить, сделать это максимально креативно, но практически неконтролируемо, можно сделать это в Mid Journey.
Если ты хочешь немного его поменять, посмотреть какие-то дополнительные новые вариации, можно сделать это внутри Cree с их собственной моделью, либо там моделью, например, Flux.
И если хочешь внести какие-то точечные, совсем маленькие изменения, можно сделать это в проприетарной модели, которая лучше это выполняет.
Следующий подход это Reference Based.
Это не одно входное изображение, а несколько референсов, каждый со своей ролью.
Чем Reference Based отличается от Image to Image?
В Image to Image модель перерисовывает референс, он остается в кадре просто в другом виде.
В Reference Based референс служит источником информации и сам в кадр не попадает.
Это разные операции и их нельзя путать.
И самих вариантов референсов у нас может быть три.
Первый из них это Style Reference.
Обычно сокращается до sRef, например, в том же Mid Journey.
Модель смотрит на референс и берет оттуда только стиль.
Это палитра, текстура, общая атмосфера.
А сюжет изображения, то, что там на нем находится, уже ваш, тот, что вы описываете в Prompt.
Это главный механизм для серии в одном стиле.
Подробно мы еще посмотрим, покрутим этот подход в конкретном инструменте.
Следующий это Character Array.
Следующий это Character Reference или C-Ref.
Модель удерживает персонажа, пропорции лица, типичные позы, узнаваемые черты.
Это полезно, когда у вас в серии один герой и он должен быть одинаковым везде.
И Multi Reference.
Модель принимает несколько референсов одновременно с разными ролями.
Один на стиль, второй на персонажа, третий на палитру.
С этим хорошо справляется Flux 2 Pro.
Он принимает до 10 изображений одновременно.
Это серьезный инструмент для жестко контролируемых серий.
Но в каждом из агрегаторов, в котором мы обычно используем Flux, он работает немного по-разному.
Где-то сегодня он работает.
То есть, например, Cree, Hicksfield, Vivi.
Везде в каждом из них есть Flux 2 Pro.
Но сегодня он будет лучше работать в одном месте, завтра в другом.
Поэтому отследить это, как-то проверить и узнать практически невозможно.
Просто к этому нужно быть готовыми.
Итак, дальше мы переходим к редактированию конкретных изображений.
Если до этого мы их полностью перерисовывали или брали оттуда, например, только стиль,
то теперь поговорим о том, как нам доработать тот визуал, который нас практически устраивает.
При доработке у нас есть два конкретных подхода.
Первый InPainting - это точечная замена области в уже существующем изображении.
Вы маскируете кусок изображения, вы выбираете область на изображении, которая называется маска.
Внутри этой маски модель рисует.
Тут как бы все максимально просто.
Просто нужно запомнить, что такое маска и где она применяется.
Этот термин в ходе твоей работы с моделями будет возникать.
Если нужно убрать какую-нибудь лишнюю деталь, объект на фоне или наоборот дорисовать в этой области что-то,
мы используем InPainting.
И второй режим - это OutPainting.
Это не перерисовка, не изменение, а дорисовка нашего изображения.
Например, берете картинку 16х9, вам нужно ее адаптировать под формат 9х16,
добавляете недостающие поля и запускаете генерацию.
Модель дорисовывает по краям, удерживая стиль и настроение.
Опять же, Rocket Science тут никакого нет, просто нам нужно запомнить эти формулировки.
Они будут у нас встречаться.
Уже продолжительное время очень хороший InPainting у чата GPT.
Он круто перерисовывает точечные моменты на изображении.
И OutPainting - это, на самом деле, не сильно требовательный процесс.
С ним справляется, как правило, Stable Diffusion.
Делает он это быстро, практически не стоит токенов.
Чаще всего будем использовать его.
Итак, теперь давайте посмотрим карту решений по подходам.
Если нам нужно начать с нуля, у нас нет исходника.
Мы хотим сделать первую итерацию какой-то иллюстрации - Text to Image.
Если мы хотим превратить визуал уже в финальное изображение,
нам нужно довести его как-то стилистически, по деталям - Image to Image.
Если мы хотим сделать серию в одном стиле,
несколько изображений, которые должны выглядеть консистентно,
мы загружаем те, что уже получились в качестве референса
и в этой же стилистике продолжаем генерацию.
И чтобы доработать точечно или адаптировать под разные форматы,
у нас есть In и OutPainting.
И что здесь самое главное?
Все это складывается, как правило, в один pipeline.
Как обычно, выглядит создание вот какого-то крутого изображения.
Начинаем с Text to Image, описываем то, что нас вдохновляет, что нам нравится.
Открываем креативную модель и используем Text to Image.
Описываем, что нам нравится, какую композицию мы видим,
может быть какие-то референс стили.
И получаем там пачку крутых креативных визуалов.
Делаем это мы, как правило, в Mid Journey, поскольку это самая креативная модель.
Начинаем нащупывать то, что нас устраивает.
Переходим в Image to Image.
Там же в Mid Journey, например, можно создать варианты, найти эталонный, тот, который ближе всех к правде.
Либо забираем этот результат и в какой-нибудь крее или любом другом редакторе делаем то же самое.
После чего, когда мы нащупываем практически идеальный результат через InPainting и OutPainting,
мы дорабатываем точечно визуал и расширяем его, адаптируем под разные форматы.
И в конечном итоге закидываем на upscale, получаем в максимальном качестве это изображение.
По подходам на этом все. Обязательно запоминаем терминологию, запоминаем pipeline, который мы обычно используем для генерации изображений.
Все это мы будем применять уже при нодовой генерации и в конкретных инструментах в дальнейшем.
Важно это запомнить для того, чтобы комфортно по ним ориентироваться.
Домашнего задания не будет. Увидимся в следующем уроке.